ich habe mich heute geärgert mal wieder
über gruner ich weiß die stammzuschauer
werden es nicht mehr hören können aber
ich kann nicht oft genug über das thema
reden und zwar gibt es wieder eine neue
aktion diesmal kommt sie aus hessen und
20 volker bouffier dazu entschieden dass
er auch zwei die 2g regel auf den
einzelhandel ausweitet das bedeutet und
das ist kein scherz ist kein fake news
im supermarkt kann jetzt auch zwei geht
verhängt werden das ist für mich
wirklich ist so unfassbar dass ich kaum
weise wie wir gleich darüber diskutieren
wollen denn das bedeutet ganz klar dass
menschen die sich dagegen entschieden
beschimpfen zu lassen wenn die
supermärkte es umsetzen sollten die
zweijährige die jetzt ja in hessen
erlaubt ist dann dürften menschen die
keine impfung haben nicht in den
supermarkt gehen würde es dann bald
annonce in der zeitung geben ich biete
12 euro die stunde für geimpften der für
mich in den supermarkt geht das sind
alles langsam eine form an die
wahnsinnig ist und ich bin dafür dass
die impfpflicht durch die hintertür die
wir längst haben in deutschland endlich
fällt
ja ich würde das agents insbesondere
weil es ein viel zu kleines details in
der debatte wir sollten bei der
impfquote die wir in deutschland haben
wer darüber nachdenken wie wir weit
reichende lockerungen in der
landespolitik endlich vornehmen und
nicht über ein kleines detail zweig
sprechen gerade die supermärkte haben in
der pandemie ganz am anfang deutlich
gemacht dass sie wo wir noch alle über
konzepte nachgedacht haben die besten
konzepte schon hatten und deshalb ist
das ein schritt der völlig zu weit geht
auch für unsere freiheit zum grundrecht
ich habe mich in hessen schon oft
gefragt was die grünen dort in dieser
schwarz grünen koalition alles
mitgemacht haben da habe ich nur noch
gestaunt die haben auch pannen des
verfassungsschutzes verschleiert und
waren nicht bereit akten rauszurücken
für untersuchungsausschüsse etc und
jetzt machen die bei dieser aktion mit
das war mal eine freiheitspartei ich
meine das ist immer noch eine hat ja ja
aber die grünen weiß ich nicht so
richtig grün weil die partei die
eigentlich wie hart ist maria ich weiß
die haben ja auch mehrfach sich im
bundestag gescheut diesen diesen
notstand den wir da haben endlich außer
kraft zu setzen momente wieder in ihrer
rechte kommen aber sowas zu beschließen
ich sag nur darauf ich würde jeden
einzelhändler warnen sich darauf
einzulassen denn ich finde wer geimpfte
boykottiert gehört selbst boykottiert in
einen solchen kämpfte in ein wehr
ungeimpfte boykottiert gehört selbst
boykottiert ich würde in einem solchen
supermarkt keinen fuß mehr setzen ich
finde wir müssen mal über volker
bouffier sprechen das ist ja der mann
von vorvorgestern offenbar der gar
nichts mehr mitbekommt man hat das
gefühl volker bouffier läuft durch
deutschland und kriegte ich mir so
richtig mit was die menschen einlassen
die voraussetzungen bundespost er
deswegen bin ich ganz sicher nicht
bundespräsident es ist auf jeden fall so
dass dieser mann sozusagen ja ganz
entscheidend mit dafür gesorgt hat dass
armin laschet kanzlerkandidat wurde dass
er auch in hessen ganz viel verstolpert
hat und jetzt dass ich finde es wird
zeit dass volker bouffier abgelöst wird
aber was passiert eigentlich wenn jemand
so einen vorschlag macht in der frage
einer daseinsvorsorge ich meine wer ihn
über supermärkte über lebenserhaltende
produkte und da sage ich ich schließe
leute aus die nicht geimpft sind ja wir
sollten einmal nur gucken wie es dazu
gekommen ist es gab ja ein urteil das
wissen wir alle im letzte woche das
verwaltungsgericht in frankfurt hat
entschieden dass ein fachgeschäfte
grillfest in grünau diese zweig regel
anwenden kann und daraufhin wurde dann
diese zweig regel andere auch quasi auf
den weg gebracht weil mir gedacht wenn
das gericht schon so entscheidet dann
schaffen wir jetzt ja ich das zu stoppen
aber mich hat paul auch total überrascht
dass volker bouffier dazu gesagt hat er
nämlich gesagt wir gehen davon aus dass
diese tat dieser option er nur tageweise
genutzt wird ja was soll das denn mit
dreisten tageweise nachweise morgens
mittags abends also entweder habe ich
diese zweig und ich glaube und die das
wirklich völlig recht die menschen
werden gucken wer wendet das an und dann
würden sie sagen dann gehe ich nicht
mehr hin den die option muss meint der
bleiben testen oder impfen oder genesen
sein aber die dritte option eben mich zu
testen oder nichts worüber haben als
dass sich in einem supermarkt keine
maske mehr tragen muss das geht mir so
gegen den strich jedes mal wenn ich da
einkaufen aber dass sich das auf dem
rücken von unerfüllter um die maske
loszuwerden dürfen die denn die waren
des grundbedarfs da nicht mehr einkaufen
das geht überhaupt nicht das kann auch
nicht justiz fest solange nicht
vorstellen einsatz und der war richtig
gut wäre ungeimpfte boykottiert wird
selbst bei
auch schon langsam los leute notieren wo
irgendwie noch die 2g regel ist um das
auch fest seien auch für sich selber für
später wenn corona mal vorbei ist und
deswegen glaube ich auch als beispiel
ich habe jetzt auch mein friseur
gewechselt weil er auch nur noch zwei
geben macht und da werde ich auch glaube
ich später nach gronau nicht mehr
hingehen ich muss auch sagen man muss da
ganz klar jetzt mal auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fair ist
und nicht richtig ist aber supermärkte
ist halt auch noch eine überhöhung ja
das muss man ja auch ganz ohne
unterschied zur restaurants restaurant
musst du nicht gehen gehört nicht
sondern grund von gestern anderswo nicht
zwei gehen wir wollen ja ja das ist ja
das bringt man unversorgt kannst du über
die schulter werfen aber lebensmittel zu
kaufen für für das tägliche leben und
zwar einem nahe gelegenen supermarkt ein
paar ältere leute von bedeutung wie weit
ist der weg habe ich ein auto oder wie
komme ich da überhaupt hin und wie
transportiert die sachen ab da gibt es
eine eingeschränkte wahlmöglichkeit und
da ist es muss es tabu sein und da muss
man auch als gesetzgeber wissen wenn man
so etwas auf den weg bringt das ja
wahrscheinlich für mehrere branchen der
fall war dass man da ausnahmetatbestand
braucht nicht gerade in supermärkte
waren ja die orte die wir an der
härtesten phase der pandemie noch
geöffnet bender wie kann man dann so ab
juli bereits sicher gehen dass auch
wirklich weiter gemacht wo man noch gar
nicht wusste wie die pandemie weiter
ablaufen wird das schöne ist auch die
wirtschaft hat wollte auch schon
reagiert und zb eigen wird die
zweijährige nicht anwenden also daran
merkt man auch wieder die wirtschaft ist
in mancher weise dann auch schon weiter
als vielleicht die politik die das
vielleicht zu lassen würde aber nicht
dass wir jetzt nach der zwei geräte eine
3g regel für die supermärkte diskutieren
weil die wäre auch viel zu weiterer
testen lassen wenn man zehn eier kaufen
will wo kommen wir da hin also das
könnte die konsequenz sein daraus ja
grundsätzlich finde schon dass man diese
3g regel anwenden sollte wo man eine
zweig regel ins werk setzen die nicht
bei supermärkten ganz klar es gibt ja
viele viele arten dieser hat
mittlerweile stadien und sie sollte man
als er zurückkam das ist gut so schlau
weil jeder der sagt ich will nicht muss
die möglichkeit haben sich frei zu
testen und dahin zu gehen das gilt
einfach zu den grundwerten und auslandes
hertha hat ja glaube ich am anfang genau
das richtige gesagt wir sind inzwischen
in einer situation wo wir nicht mehr
über zusätzliche verschärfungen reden
sollten sondern darüber wieder wieder
impfstatus deutschlands die
wiederherstellung von freiheit glaubt
und in dem in dem stadium sind wir es
sind ungefähr 80% zweimal geimpft dann
kommen noch die genesenen oben drauf da
kann man jetzt nur grob schätzen wie
viele sind es 85 bis 90 worauf warten
wir eigentlich noch heute das absolut
ich meine herren findet man muss die
epidemiologische lage endlich beenden so
zu sagen ich das ist ich meine wir wir
sind nicht mehr dort wo wir vor ein paar
monaten waren es ist einfach eine andere
komplett andere lage komplett andere
situation
und so ein zeichen zu setzen als
ministerpräsident geht in die völlig
falsche richtung das da hat man das
gefühl es kommt als nächstes der lok tor
ja ein paar karmann ist mehr als der
politik und warum reagiert denn auch die
pflege also wieso reden wirklich mehr
viel mehr gerät was ist denn da los also
worauf kann sich der bürger nächsten
morgen gefasst machen ja ich denke das
ist sozusagen geprägt durch angela
merkel durch die kanzlerin und helge
braun die man auch sagen ganz vorsichtig
und dann schlimmen und dann malt wieder
helge braun und welche kurven nachts und
denkt mensch war das eine schöne zeit
als ich ganz wichtig war und irgendwie
kurven malen konnte das jetzt böse aber
natürlich spielt hier eine große rolle
ganz ernster und ich glaube dass sie
nicht so richtig ablassen können von dem
thema und sozusagen sich da auch wichtig
für glaube es wird schon viel ausmachen
ehrlich es ist keine überbewertung
dieses mannes wenn karl lauterbach mal
in die comedy abgewandert ist und macht
dort lustigen aufführungen im fernsehen
sogar eine zentralgestalt der ständigen
angst verbreitung weg und das macht viel
aus weil der stößt wieder andere an und
mehr als jahren rätsel wie dieser mann
ein fdp-politiker hat einen bestimmten
ausdruck gefunden den ich gar nicht
schlecht fand aber den ich jetzt hier
nicht wiederhole ich habe mich wie
dieser mann hat mich
eingeladen wird um seine sogenannte
expertise auszubreiten
leute wacht super muss ich sagen als
mann der doch er steht halt auf einer
seite zieht das durch er sagt immer ich
habe jetzt wieder eine studie gelesen
und das ist ganz schlimm und das muss
ich tun wenn ich es steht einfach für
sein thema ein und so das ist ja ich
glaube er steht für sicherheit weil das
ja das glaube ich nicht also gut er will
gesundheitsminister werden wird er nicht
weil man ist also da wäre oder schutz
natürlich wahnsinnig
mit dem klima
nichts grundsätzlich schlechtes oder
schlimme ist ich finde er steht total
glaubwürdige für die position die er
noch mal hat und die müssen wir genauso
akzeptieren wie deine position oder
andere bewältigt werden der wegen des im
wahlkampf thematisiert hat das thema hat
die menschen bewegt im wahlkampf ist war
aber kein thema im wahlkampf immer
weiter ich glaube schon dass menschen
das bewegt hat mir frage der freiheit im
übrigen auch klar wie viel einschränkung
ist eigentlich noch vertretbar und wie
viel ist überzogen mittlerweile so sind
sie ja zweistellig geworden denn wenn
sie die seien aber nicht in berlin
leider sind aber bundesweit
ja aber ich meine wir sollten viel mehr
darüber reden als über das auslaufmodell
karl lauterbach wir sollten doch eher
über die frage sprechen wie können wir
die pandemie bedingten muscle wieder
zurückfahren ich glaube wenn es ja
sobald es eine neue regierung gibt das
ist auch die antwort auf die frage warum
tun die jetzt nix weil das ist endphase
einer bundesregierung jeder denkt an
sich was mache ich danach was werde in
der cdu und vor weiter und so fort da
gibt es keinen mehr der das heft in die
hand nimmt und in den ländern ist es
sowieso so wenn es eine neue regierung
gibt muss mindestens die fdp anfang in
der regierung die frage zu stellen dann
steigen wir einige aus dem mars
[Musik]